hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game you guys requested also
from round six of this year's fed Grand
Swiss it is Samuel seian versus javak
sarov and um it's well it's a really
wild game but it's also a very short one
only 23 moves and so far both Samuel and
javir are undefeated in the tournament
now it's very hard to pinpoint the exact
point of no return in this game for uh
the losing player but we will do it
nevertheless so let's check it out uh
Samuel has the white pieces and he opens
with C4 he goes for the English opening
we have G6 the so-called Great Snake
variation E4 and now Pawn to E5 we have
Knight to F3 Bishop to G7 and pawn to D4
striking in the center uh we have e
captures on D4 Knight captures and now
Knight to F6 we have Knight to C3 and
here jav castles we have Bishop to E3
and pawn to C6 now preparing to strike
in the center with Pawn to D5 uh there
are some games where Bishop D2 with
played but here we have Queen to D2 and
it is now as of move eight that we have
a completely new game so okay Joker
continues developing putting pressure on
that E4 Pawn so just Pawn to F3
defending it and now Pawn to
D5 uh of course you want to open up the
center as your opponent's king is still
occupying D1 square e captures on D5 C
captures on D5 and now white doesn't
develop the bishop and Castle King side
white actually castles Queen side so uh
what happens now Knight to C6 we have
Knight captures and C6 B captures and
now Bishop to D4 here uh you might um
consider some other moves but this is a
very very strong piece of course you are
expecting um jaok to put the Rook on B8
maybe the queen comes to B6 not at the
moment when the bishop moves uh and uh
you will have a lot of pressure on this
diagonal and on the B file so definitely
it makes sense to counter uh jav strong
dark Square Bishop on G7 and now we have
Rook to B8 here uh this is sort of the
point of no return but we're going to
get to this position after we check out
the entire game so here C captures and
D5 was played grabbing a pawn but now
not C captures and D5 but rather Pawn to
C5 and how do you how do you play this H
well there are you have to move the
bishop somewhere or you you capture the
pawn on C5 but let's say you capture on
F6 then you get Queen captures on F6 and
after Bishop to C4 H you will play
Bishop Bop to F5 uh close off this
diagonal so the king cannot escape to B1
and A1 and now let's say we play Pawn to
G4 Bishop goes back to D7 okay the game
continues with black having a lot of
pressure on the B file and on this
diagonal but that's something that we
already mentioned and you can't really
prevent this so that's one way to play
it uh in the game Samuel decided to
capture on C5 he played Bishop captures
on C5 and now it's even more dangerous
Queen to A5 now puts pressure on the
bishop Bishop to D B6 now attacks the
rook and now comes Bishop to F5 here
objectively best is just to move the
rook and black is completely winning but
jaer played Bishop to F5 and now you
actually have a chance um to fight but
it's very very hard to calculate in the
game uh Pawn to G4 was played and this
simply will not do uh what you have to
do is capture The Rook on B8 I'm just
going to show it because it's a lot of
fun and after Rook captures he going to
play Bishop to C4 to not just the def
the pawn but also to be able to play
Bishop to B3 and Bishop back to C2 so if
Queen B4 you just block Bishop to B3 and
now if Rook to C8 you just block The
Rook again with Bishop to C2 and now if
Knight captures on D5 you can go for
Queen captures and D5 Bishop captures
and C3 B captures and C3 and queen
captures and C3 and yes it looks like
you're getting destroyed here but you
actually get to survive Queen to B3 and
now white black has nothing better than
to trade Queen captures Queen captures
Rook captures threatening some windmill
action here but you will only get the H
pick up two pawns nothing nothing more
King A1 and now you're going to go after
the A2 Pawn as well that doesn't matter
if white pushes it Forward doesn't push
it forward if you push it then just Rook
A2 with check and after the king moves
Rook captures on A4 and here you would
have this position where it's uh two
Rooks and two pawns versus a rook bishop
and four pawns all in all should be
should be a draw but uh of course you
have a lot of Co play there instead of
after Bishop to F5 G4 was played uh sort
of the idea is the same only once the
bishop moves you're going to play Bishop
captur on B8 but that's just the thing
Joker does not move the bishop he plays
Rook B to C8 and now you really have
nothing better than to capture the
bishop on F5 so G captures on F5 now
comes Knight captures on D5 and F
captures on G6 look at all this pressure
on C3 absolutely incredible stuff here
sorry about that Arrow uh h captures and
G6 and now finally you start capturing
Knight captures and C3 Bishop to H3
going after the Rook here and Knight
captures on C3 we have Bishop captures
and C8 Rook captures on C8 and now Queen
to D3 uh we have Queen captures on A2
and now Bishop to C7 one last trick if
black captures the bishop then you can
play Queen to d8 check even though even
with this um black would still be
winning so uh here Knight captures on D1
was played uh and he was in this
position un move 23 that Samuel savian
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you're down a piece
uh you're going to be down more material
soon and if you play Queen captur and D1
then Queen captur and B2 is Checkmate so
that doesn't work if you capture back
with the King just one check picks up
the Rook on H1 so that doesn't work you
are out of moves and uh well here of
course that's why he resigned so
beautifully played by by jaer but I I
just wanted to go back to that position
where Rook to B8 was played where I said
we've reached the point of no return uh
where C captures and D5 was played the
only way to continue here is to not play
that is to play Bishop to D3 and now
okay why black still gets to play C5 but
now after Bishop captures and D captures
and C4 you just play Bishop captures and
C4 and now it's fine if if black trades
Queens okay you're not going to get
checkmated uh you can play this and if
black keeps the Queens in the game with
something like Queen to C7 then you get
Bishop to D6 and now it's much much
different Queen captures on C4 now you
eliminate The Rook from the B file and
okay it's still going to be uh you know
a nice game let's say Bishop to F5
Bishop to D6 but you are in the game
there's no way for black to force
anything here and um it can uh still be
played but yeah only move 13 and already
here the the critical mistake C captures
on D5 uh you know incredible stuff but
what are you going to do it's it's a
sharp opening um this great snake
variation the adorian defense and uh
well just 23 moves very very nicely done
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for recommending
such a wonderful miniature I really hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank the
brers on Spotify Steven McAn chess beats
League Roman manini and Sam's giant
tortois farm for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day in today's round Fabiano
corana will be facing radav vashek on
board one so we'll see what happens uh
see you
soon